imaginons une grille d'espace-temps
simplifiée à deux dimensions
on imagine un axe temporel qu'on notera
T et un axe spatial qu'on notera X
ce référentiel ici représente un
référentiel inertiel c'est à dire que
tous les objets qui s'y déplacent sans
subir aucune force trace des lignes
droites
on va imaginer que ce référentiel
correspond à un observateur une personne
qui reste donc immobile le long de l'axe
temporel
cette personne repère n'importe quel
événement de l'espace-temps avec des
coordonnées T et X alors par convention
on notera plutôt les vecteurs de façon
verticale avec la composante temporelle
en premier
et on ajoutera un facteur de conversion
ici pour la composante temporelle de
sorte à utiliser les mêmes unités pour
les distances spatiales et les durées
donc les distances temporelles
ici donc notre axe t se transforme en
axe C foisé alors ce C ici on peut le
voir uniquement comme un facteur de
conversion entre les maîtres et les
secondes par exemple mais il s'avère
qu'il est très pratique d'utiliser la
vitesse de la lumière ou plus
précisément la vitesse invariante de
l'espace-temps cette constante de la
relativité restreinte qui va nous
intéresser par la suite
alors imaginons maintenant un autre
observateur par exemple une voiture qui
se déplace par rapport à notre première
observateur
donc la voiture a un mouvement au cours
du temps elle se déplace dans l'espace
et donc son axe temporel le long duquel
elle est immobile est différent de celui
du premier observateur
en conséquence son axe spatial va lui
aussi être différent
et chaque événement de l'espace-temps
pour cette voiture sera repéré avec des
coordonnées différentes
donc un même événement aura des
coordonnées différentes selon
l'observateur qu'il observe et donc
selon le référentiel qu'on utilise
le problème qui va nous intéresser
aujourd'hui c'est de déterminer la
transformation qui permet de passer d'un
référentiel à l'autre et plus
précisément d'un système de coordonnées
à un autre en relativité restreinte
alors pour commencer une première
remarque que l'on peut faire c'est que
d'un référentiel inertiel à un autre
toutes les trajectoires en ligne droite
restent des lignes droites les vitesses
changent les directions changent mais
les trajectoires en ligne droite n'ont
aucune raison de s'incurver ou de
changer de forme lorsqu'on passe d'un
référentiel à un autre
et ça ça va nous arranger puisque ça
veut dire qu'on peut écrire la
transformation des coordonnées comme une
transformation linéaire
alors une transformation linéaire on
peut la formaliser sous la forme d'une
matrice qu'on va appeler lambda
majuscule et dont les composantes seront
montés alpha beta gamma et Delta
l'idée ici c'est qu'on va essayer de
déterminer ses composantes pour savoir
comment en appliquant cette matrice un
vecteur ses coordonnées se transforment
la première condition cruciale que l'on
souhaite imposer c'est le fait que la
vitesse de la lumière doit rester
invariante ça c'est vraiment l'axiome
fondamental de la relativité restreinte
sur lequel se base toute la théorie
on va imaginer un rayon lumineux qui se
déplace et l'idée assez cruciale c'est
que la direction de ce rayon lumineux
est fixée sa vitesse est invariante elle
est constante elle vaut petit C et donc
lorsqu'un certain temps s'écoule donc
c'est Delta T ou Delta t c'est le temps
qui s'est écoulé la distance qu'il a
parcouru Delta x vaut forcément Delta t
XC
donc ce deltaïque ici vaut également C
fois Delta t ce que ça signifie c'est
que le vecteur ici a simplement une
pente de 1 et pour simplifier on pourra
noter qu'il vaut 1 1
de la même façon on peut imaginer un
rayon lumineux qui partent dans l'autre
sens ce rayon s'écoule toujours dans le
temps mais il se déplace dans l'autre
sens spatialement et donc son delta X
est négatif
l'idée c'est que ces deux vecteurs ici 1
1 et 1 - 1 doivent rester invariant
alors leur norme peut changer mais la
direction du rayon lumineux dans
l'espace-temps qui indique sa vitesse ne
peut pas changer alors voyons comment la
matrice lambda s'applique à ces deux
vecteurs
déjà on peut commencer par appliquer
lambda à ce vecteur 1 1
et ce qu'on veut imposer c'est que ceci
valent le même vecteur donc le vecteur
reste invariant avec peut-être
potentiellement un changement de normes
donc ici on va appeler lambda un facteur
multiplicatif mais l'idée c'est que les
deux composantes ici doivent rester égal
entre elles
alors on va appliquer cette matrice de
façon explicite
on a la matrice alphabéta gamma delta et
si on peut calculer le produit matriciel
donc on obtient un vecteur qui a pour
composante alpha + beta et gamma plus
Delta
et ceci doit être égal à lambda lambda
alors ici on voit qu'on obtient une
première équation assez importante on
voit que ceci doit forcément être égal à
ceci puisque les deux Valenta donc notre
première équation
alpha + beta
= gamma plus Delta
alors maintenant on peut faire le même
raisonnement avec l'autre vecteur ici on
remplace simplement 1 1 par 1 - 1 ici
également 1 - 1 et donc ici on obtient
lambda moins lambda ici il faut faire
attention le produit matriciel a changé
on a cette fois-ci alpha - beta
et gamma moins Delta
et à partir d'ici on obtient à nouveau
une nouvelle équation il suffit de
changer le signe des deux côtés sur la
composante du bas et à nouveau on
obtient que ceci doit être égal à ceci
et donc que Alpha - beta cette fois-ci
doit être égal à - gamma plus Delta
alors ces deux équations elles sont très
intéressantes puisqu'elles vont nous
permettre de résoudre pour deux
composantes de la matrice
alors pour commencer on peut additionner
les deux équations si on les additionne
on voit ici qu'on obtient 2 alphas les
bêtas s'annulent
les gamma s'annulent et on obtient deux
de Delta
en divisant par 2 on obtient que Alpha =
Delta et donc ici le delta on peut
explicitement le remplacer par Alpha
de la même façon on peut cette fois-ci
soustraire les deux équations
alors si on soustrait ici alpha moins
alpha s'annule bêta plus bêta donne deux
bêta
gamma plus gamma donne deux gamma et les
Delta s'annulent on obtient béta = gamma
et donc explicitement on peut remplacer
gamma par bêta
cette simple condition le fait d'avoir
imposé l'invariance de la vitesse de la
lumière nous a grandement restreint sur
la forme de la matrice on voit qu'il
doit s'agir forcément d'une matrice où
les composantes opposées sont égales
à partir de là on va essayer donc de
déterminer les composantes alpha et bêta
et ça tombe bien on a deux composantes à
déterminer et on a deux restrictions qui
nous restent à utiliser
la première restriction qu'on a vu c'est
que le vecteur de la voiture doit
devenir immobile lorsque l'on passe dans
le référentiel de la voiture
alors le vecteur de la voiture je vais
l'écrire en vert
c'est le vecteur c'est V
alors pourquoi ce vecteur tout
simplement puisque si la voiture se
déplace à une vitesse V donc V ici
représente la vitesse de la voiture et
bien en l'espace d'un intervalle de
temps Delta t la voiture se déplace d'un
intervalle d'espace Delta X qui vaut sa
vitesse fois le temps qui s'est écoulé
donc le vecteur ici qui est c Delta T
avec Delta x vaut c'est Delta T et si en
composant de spatiale V Delta T et comme
ce qui nous intéresse c'est uniquement
la direction de ce vecteur on peut
supprimer les Delta T et on obtient bien
le vecteur CV
ce qui nous intéresse c'est que ce
vecteur se transforme en un vecteur
immobile spatialement donc spatialement
ça veut dire que sa composante spatiale
doit valoir 0 et la composante
temporelle nous nous intéresse pas
vraiment elle va valoir quelque chose de
différent mais ça nous intéresse pas
vraiment
donc on peut faire ça on peut appliquer
la matrice lambda au vecteur c'est V et
imposer que ceci doivent valoir un
vecteur de composantes spatiale nulle
alors remplaçons explicitement la
matrice
alpha beta beta alpha
ici le produit matriciel donne alphac
plus bêta V mais cette première
composante ne nous intéresse pas c'est
la deuxième qui nous intéresse et on
obtient beta c plus alphabet
ceci doivent valoir 0 et donc on obtient
une nouvelle équation
qui nous dit que beta c plus alphabet
= 0
alors là c'est très bien puisqu'on peut
déterminer la valeur de bêta en fonction
de Alpha si on divise par C des deux
côtés on obtient beta plus alpha V sur C
= 0 et en soustrayant ceci des deux
côtés on obtient que beta est égal à -
Alphabet sur C
donc ici explicitement dans la matrice
je vais remplacer beta par - Alphabet
sur C
on approche du but mais il nous reste
une dernière composante à déterminer
c'est ce facteur Alpha qui en fait est
un facteur global pour toute la matrice
et ça tombe bien puisqu'il ne reste une
dernière hypothèse une dernière
restriction à utiliser c'est le fait que
cette matrice si l'on remplace V par - v
doivent correspondre au changement de
référentiel inverse et donc en
particulier lambda multiplié par lambda
où l'on aurait remplacé V par - v ceci
doit nous ramener au référentiel de
départ c'est à dire que ceci doit donner
une transformation
triviale la matrice identité
alors on peut faire ce calcul
explicitement une fois de plus la
matrice lambda c'est alpha moins
alphabet sur C moins alphabet sur C
alpha la matrice lambda on le replace V
par - v C'est alpha + alpha V sur C +
alphabet sur C et Alpha
et la matrice identité c'est 1 0 0 1
les 0 qui sont ici on voit qu'on les
obtient assez trivialement si on fait le
calcul matriciel on va avoir donc dans
pour cette composante par exemple on va
voir alpha x alpha V sur C moins
alphabet sur C x alpha donc forcément ça
fait 0 et la même chose ici par contre
c'est 1 ici ne nous sont pas forcément
donnés on voit que si l'on essaie de
calculer cette composante on obtient
alpha au carré moins alphabet sur C au
carré
donc ici on a une équation qui nous
donne que Alpha carré donc cette
composante fois cette composante plus
cette composante fois cette composante
donc moins alpha carré V carré sur C
carré doit valoir
alors ici on peut factoriser par Alpha
carré
ceci doit valoir 1 et pour finir on
obtient que Alpha
= 1 sur Racine Carré de 1 - v carré sur
ces carrés alors on pourrait avoir un
alpha = - ceci
le problème c'est que si l'on mettait
moins ceci ça changerait simplement
l'orientation du référentiel nous on ne
veut pas ça on veut que nos axes
changent de façon continue et donc en
particulier qui ne changent pas de
l'orientation et donc on prend le signe
positif pour Alpha et voilà on a terminé
le calcul la matrice lambda vaut donc
pour terminer 1 sur Racine de 1 - v
carré sur C carré
facteur 2 1 1 donc ici j'ai factorisé
par Alpha et - V sur C moins V sur C
cette matrice elle est extrêmement
importante en relativité restreinte
c'est la fameuse matrice de Lorentz
et vous reconnaissez peut-être ici le
facteur de Lawrence qui est
caractéristique de tous les effets de la
relativité restreinte